Salam alaikum guys how you doing I'm all
for us that happy before we get into
this week's show we show us a move for
the people and motivate them to start
playing what you got first let's start
with a arm Jay what's doing okay so my
partner's has watch whatever guys were
pushing each other very common scenario
and fighting watch them I'm going to do
the old wax on wax off I'm just gonna do
like this grunt kid all right if you're
the kid you guys are already kid right
every wrong party kit so we feel it
locked up watch I'm going to that white
Sun I'm gonna capture there is let's see
that again locked up or pushing each
other wax on
capture the wrist for drag the arm
across his body and capture it with your
left hand
okay so once again I'm doing the wax on
wax off with my right hand I'm seeing
these tricep to my left hand I'm pulling
his arm across pulling it forward for
our zombie on Daddy's show don't go
anywhere be right back Salam alaikum
guys welcome back to the Dean show in
the Dean show studio for our hobby
assalamu alaikum peace be with you how
are you Brad I can set my brother we
finally get to hug finally I'm very
excited me too happy to be here happy to
have you here with us
I remember and I was very elated few
years back we did a program and we had a
message in there for George st. Pierre
there's a famous UFC Ultimate Fighting
Championship fighter
George st. some chairs and pas you guys
you speak the same language into George
yeah I love the results that matter si
do the donations the viola something
that voila
and cocoa energy keep em attracted
search was admirably extraordinaire do a
kappa de Longueville OC at a to momo
Saturnalia le pas and Zappa Champa a
newsie Dhoni a with a versatility but
that syrup Lisa Dieker at mimosa be
partyi equipos de peche a it was de
peche Li
thus happily at home SEC to Scotland you
do not publish on the Curia would say
jerking don't look as you drop literally
dirty porno Winnick Montano Khun Danai
leprosy detail XE dr I'm gonna call
media inshallah beautiful
God well message gets to him and I was
very elated that you had shared that
with him
and you stayed within my heart for since
then and I made do I was like I'd like
to meet this brother one day and here
you are having a little hamdulillah how
you been how originally from Canada no
your family's from my parents are from
Lebanon I'm born and raised in Montreux
yeah speaking of George st. Pierre it's
interesting we're fat you're fasting now
mm-hmm
I'm fasting and it's just a few years
back I didn't see I don't know if it
because I wasn't paying attention but
it's very interesting now all of the the
ton of information on fasting I was so
shocked even to see that George st.
Pierre he's made it a lifestyle also is
that's true that's true no he's doing a
lot of fasting these days he absolutely
met a doctor that treat people with
cancer and diabetes with intermittent
fasting so I started doing a program of
intermitted fasting and time restricted
eating and now my symptom diminish like
every every weeks every month diminish
so he's got it's getting better
it's not a hundred percent now but he's
getting a lot better a lot better and I
feel a lot better yeah so now what do
you I mean back then people were just
like well how can you guys do that how
can you cuz we're staying away from the
pre obviously you know before dawn
breaks we'll get up eat and then all the
weight right now it's like until almost
nine o'clock or stay away from food and
water and people just just amazed how
can you do that but there are you seeing
so many more people now intermediate
fasting so many more people are there's
so much more data I mean we don't
obviously do it for the physically
benefit from the physical but benefits
but more the spiritual being the Creator
who's ordained is for us are you seeing
that now so much a ton of if not I'll
definitely another's intermittent
fasting is very popular there are a lot
of benefits to fasting you know but the
number one benefit to fasting in my
is the psychological benefits and people
will I don't want I hate to use the word
addicted to fasting but people will see
that fasting is also an experience it's
also an experience because you know
again my background is in philosophy so
I have a hard time seeing anything
outside of thought people think that
pleasure or happiness or fun comes from
the outside but actually pleasure and
happiness and fun all comes from a type
of suffering when these people might
find as stated again
all pleasure all pleasure comes from
suffering from suffering from suffering
so for instance let me give you for
instance it's actually depression that
comes from satisfaction so let me
clarify that because words are a tricky
thing for instance if I'm very hungry
and I eat a steak dinner you're gonna
that steak dinner has gonna have
relieves my pain of hunger now I'm gonna
have a sensation of pleasure however if
I tell you eat that steak dinner and you
enjoy it then I bring you another steak
to eat that one to Eddie now you enjoy
it but not as much then I bring a third
and a fourth and you're like please no
more and I force you a six to seven I'm
gonna be throwing up now you're getting
sick now the same steak that gave you
pleasure and I was making you ill now
the sight of it is scaring you now you
know that this madman making me eat
steak knives torturing me mm-hmm
so where this pleasure come from the
pleasure came from your appetite
Fatima elusive Sarah and it's a cycle
right the verse repeats itself again
it's cyclical now in the West we have
over here an incredible epidemic of
depth depression we do sure why because
when I give you that first steak it was
good the second one wasn't as good the
third one you're satiated your needs are
so met all the time you're so pampered
you're so taking in the West I mean as a
Western society we have so many
resources I like to call it the
billionaires of history the
trillionaires of history we live better
than ancient kings literally speaking we
have water electricity transport food
medicine vaccinations etc we are what
Nietzsche
would call the last man you know where
that fat cat on a pillow so to speak
where the we're benefiting from all the
hard work our forefathers did to bring
society to this level and now we're numb
a bit why because we have too much
we have satiated our desires so much so
often that the second you have a slight
amount of hunger you're eating the
second you have a slight amount of
discomfort you're sheltered so what
happens that person becomes numb a happy
person goes through a cycle of pleasure
and pain a happy person goes through a
cycle of pleasure and pain so for
instance if you're very cold and I give
you a blanket you'll feel a great
sensation of warmth you'll have this
great experience however if you're
already warm and I'd put you a blanket
on you that same blanket now is causing
you discomfort so why in the West we
have the most amount of depression when
we have the most amount of resources
it's because we've over consumed now
take somebody who is addicted to
overconsumption and tell them look stop
eating and drinking for 16 20 hours it's
gonna be very hard for them why they
have a habit formed they're eating and
drinking is easy for them and actually
if you know the process of our habit is
formed in the mind it's actually quite
easy to explain why it's very difficult
for them to break a habit a habit is
just a very efficient way for your body
to do the same thing over and over again
actually saves energy by creating a
habit loop now when Ramadan comes along
we do it as a community you know when I
saw you you asked me about my Ramadan
ask you about your Ramadan we're pooling
our collective will together and in
essence one of the reasons why we do
Ramadan is to replenish that battery you
know when you're gonna have your
breakfast for the first time in 30 days
that breakfast is gonna be something
extremely special when you're going to
be doing all the things you've abstained
from in Ramadan after Ramadan you're
gonna be you can have rejuvenated your
batteries you can have refreshed your
life you can have done it again for the
first time so to speak so this cycle is
so important however in Islam we do it
as a community together and many
religious traditions have these fasting
rituals however you don't see them as
practice I would say as in Islam in
Islam it's really look the Sun comes up
man we start
eating we stop drinking and we're doing
it as a community of course Ramadan is
all is for so many reasons one of the
main reasons as well as for knowing what
a hungry person goes through Ramadan
gives you an a glimpse into the life of
person who's underprivileged somebody
who doesn't have food to eat you have a
you don't know what it's like but you
have a glimpse and personally I've had a
lot of empathy now for people personally
who don't have enough to eat like I I
find that it's such a horrible state to
be in you know could you imagine a young
child who has to do what we're doing for
should we do it for a short period of
time could you imagine somebody this is
their lifestyle mm-hmm it's a very
difficult thing it brings you back to
reality why because here in the West you
know I go to the fights a lot in Vegas
you know the food the amount of waste
the amount of stuff that just turned
away I've had enough you know this is
the fifth time I ate today and throw
away all these precious resources it's
hard to do that after you've done
Ramadan really it's hard to see that how
you start to understand the value of the
resource the resources and I think this
is this what is this more of a paradigm
shift a paradigm change and the
understanding of the self and I think
it's a it's an incredible exercise
psychologically it's beautiful when you
look at when we're told that in the
Quran where God Almighty is saying
fasting has been prescribed for you as
it was prescribed to those before you
that you may attain God consciousness
taqwa so we connect back to Jesus he
fasted Moses he fasted the best human
beings that walked the earth they fasted
so now we're seeing all these
developments physical but obviously the
spiritual you name's one of the wisdoms
but before we even get to that for us
what had you because you don't just wake
up one day say I want to start fasting I
mean you got to go through you're going
through life now and you you start to
ask yourself that cuz it starts with
that question what is the purpose of
life right and before you start
following the blue blueprint of life
that was legislated from the creator of
life what had you at what point in your
life did you start contemplating and
thinking what's the purpose of life
before you even got to fasting prayer
and all the other things
that you do today you asked me why I
contemplated doing fast will got me
there what got you to the point of yet
living purpose because obviously Islam
you're living that purpose that was
ordained by the Creator what got you to
that point that you started to think
what's the purpose of my life why am I
here why have I been created well this
is this is a very profound question all
for me I I don't like most people don't
ask that question it's very true it's a
great question
I started fasting because it was my
tradition mm-hm and then later I
understood the benefits later okay I
understood later because I started
fasting quite young
yeah but the benefits that I reaped and
the grew up side by side with friends
who didn't have these benefits I
understood what it was so for instance
the willpower the willpower the
domination of your more your animal self
so to speak your your lower self your
your primal drives to just eat now when
a baby's born what's the first thing the
baby does cries it wants to be warmed
and eat it is your most primal instinct
now you have to wrestle with this primal
instinct and Ramadan's not only about
not eating it's also but not about
losing your temper if you're gonna lose
your temper during Ramadan we do we
don't need you to drop leave your food
and drink you might as well eat and
drink right because this is you're out
doing Ramadan or if you're lying
deceiving exactly all these Ramadan is
more than just stopping the eating yeah
you have to suppress all your primal
desires mm-hmm now if you want to be
close to Allah sport Allah you have to
do this so when you take somebody's food
away we see if he's a master of his
primal what did you I don't mean a good
job but you just said an Arabic word for
the people tuna yeah here a lost wonton
what do you if you want to be with
closer to God if God consciousness if
you want have taqwa like this some moon
God no safale no no because a lot of
people out there they don't know we're
doing the proper they don't know and
there's a lot of propaganda and see all
these Muslims knows only one they are
ships there's only one God how do we
know there's only one God how do we know
this is a very interesting idea this is
called the Abrahamic experience is this
a different God than Jesus worship stuff
Allah no there cannot be another God
what are you saying stock for Allah what
is this a philosophy so people don't
have to take an Arabic class yeah I
write my apologies my apology
you know like when you here it means
like god forbid god forbid god forbid
and I forgive I got forgiven here's the
thing okay then we get we got outlaw and
then we got snot alone we got Allah is
like god forbid you know our God forgive
Chris as the same you know look in
philosophy we have something called
compounded ideas okay I'll put it in a
simpler language I'll make it as simple
as possible you know doing philosophy
for 20 years I've learned to explain
things as simply as possible because
they make they're easier to they're
easier to understand and I get a lot
further when I simplify them was it
Bruce Lee who said that there's
brilliance and simplicity absolutely
knows him absolutely yes okay so let's
think about like this okay you have a
mountain yeah and you have gold Mountain
gold a mountain on one hand then you
have gold in the one hand and I put them
together and I have a golden mountain
okay mm-hmm now have you ever seen a
mountain you've seen a mountain have you
ever seen gold yes okay have you ever
seen a golden mountain I'm talking about
a literal mountain of gold like a Mount
Everest but made of gold no okay
so golden mountain is a simple idea Gold
is a simple idea we compound them now we
have a complex idea or compound that
idea I mixed ideas you might say you've
never seen this mixed idea I've never
experienced it okay now let's go example
number two you've ever seen man before a
man yes okay have you ever seen a flight
a bird flying mm-hmm okay now let's
compound them we have a Superman a
flying man we've never seen compounded
ideas in nature they may or may not
exist however we know one thing for sure
we know man exists and we know birds
exist we know flight exists you only
know about flying
this is epistemology you only know the
existence of flying because you saw in
nature a bird fly mm-hmm when you saw
that bird fly you can then look at a
rock and say oh maybe that rock I can
picture it flying now here you can mix
it in your imagination now I'll give you
another for instance you've seen
marshmallows we've seen a man okay let
me make the marshmallow man mm-hmm he
may or may not exist however the simple
idea the marshmallow
not break it down any further this
simple idea was known via experience man
was known via experience you've met a
human being who was a man and therefore
you have they have the app man all our
ideas could be traced back to somewhere
something so in the Quran
now I'm paraphrasing cuz I'm not a
Quranic scholar Abraham sees the Sun and
he says this is my Lord and he realized
it's not his Lord then he sees the moon
this is my lord this is no this is not
my lord because it sets then he sees the
stars and he says this is my lord and he
realizes no he was compounding ideas
don't forget this is the Abrahamic
experience now there's a lot to know
about this and I'm putting it in a
nutshell because a lot of scholars I
made a lot of comment on this verse this
is a very profound very strong extremely
profound verse
look we're saying when you say God of
War or God of the Sun or God of the
earth or god of the moon or god of the
love you're compounding the idea you're
made up a pseudo God we're telling you
look we have no experience this is what
the Imam has Nadia would say give us
demonstration in memores Ali was one of
the most skeptical human beings I always
tell people a true Muslim he's the most
skeptical you think you're a new
atheists or sceptical were more
skeptical than you if you truly
understand Islam you're you're not
skeptical enough for us
Sam Harris was not skeptical enough
Raymond Ali this is not extreme enough
for this skepticism to go to the to find
Allah you have to go an extreme reason
or doubt because the two are the same
okay
even our abhi it would tell you doubt
and reason when you meet them at one
place when they find their juncture now
you've come close so to speak okay so
I'll give you let me let me let me
backtrack here a little bit okay I know
it's might be a little bit out there
when somebody is born blind can you tell
him what the color red is can you
explain to him logically impossible how
impossible he has no understanding of
the color red he's born blind he's never
seen red you can make him touch this
chair and you get on this one is red
this one is orange he'll never
understand we're talking about the red
and orange however one day he's eyes are
cured and he sees the color red now
he'll only know the color red this is
known as dope by taste meaning by
experience some things are only known
via experience there's no logical
explanation all your experiences that
cannot be broken down any further are
known by dull or experienced direct
experience so for instance I have an
idea of the color red I have an idea of
the Sun because I've experienced them
directly I cannot break down the idea of
Sun any further now I can picture a red
Sun I can compound an idea this is why I
always tell people look you're either
theist or polytheists or agnostic
there's no in-between there's no such
thing I don't believe there's a theist I
don't believe it exists and I clarify
for that for you later
there is no such thing as somebody who
rejects all the gods in Islam we were
Zek we reject all the gods save one we
start off that's the proclamation
there's no God except God we are like
the atheists save one exception because
let ilaha ilallah there's no god but
Allah is a very profound statement and
if you read the Islamic philosophers the
classic philosophers the amount of
writings just on this concept it's
profound and I feel I feel obliged to
say that that Muslims need to wake up
and and read the ancient Islamic texts
the ancient philosophers the first
philosophers of Islam there they're not
in tune with the great some of the
greatest thinkers to ever walk the face
of the earth so we know why we say it's
so easy to understand there's only one
God show me any deity other than Allah
smile other than God
the one God whatever you want to call
him what language interpret what what
language you're using dear God Allah ha
you know I never make they say Allah ha
the language of Jesus hello hello heem
Elohim whatever word you want to say
because there's so many definitions of
God may only have one definition for God
I think it's the one that cannot be
escaped I believe this is the definition
of God that cannot be escaped we'll get
to that later I mean there's so much
much talk about
when you tell me a red Sun I could tell
you it may or may not exist but I don't
know it via experience all I know is
that the Sun exists and the color red
exists I know God by experience direct
experience intuition intuition direct
experience now here's a you know I you
know I I read a lot of books okay I
really tremendous amount of books and I
always like to coin the man who said it
best because a lot of men say the same
thing throughout history you'd be
shocked how many times independent
thinkers come to the same conclusion
now even otterby he said it the best you
know in philosophy we have something
called substance theory you might find
this a little bit weird okay but in
philosophy we have materialists
materialists are like everything is made
of a concrete something there's this
thing called the atom in the universe
this is classic materialism there's this
thing we call the atom and this thing is
indivisible it's unbreakable it's
eternal that always existed and this is
the only thing that exists we're just an
arrangement of matter so Eddy you're
just an arrangement of matter when you
die your matter is just gonna rearrange
and so on and so on and then we have
another theory called dualism classic
dualism is ok there's this material
substance out there there's these Legos
of the building blocks of the universe
but then there's also this mystical
non-physical thing the soul or the
essence of something non-physical and
these two the physical and non-physical
they interact this is called dualism
then you have idealism
now there's three okay so we have
materialism dualism and then idealism
idealism look there's nothing material
in this world at all it's all just
thought the world is just like a dream
state now substance theory is very
complex philosophers we debate it
continuously however there's one
philosopher I've come across recently
that totally threw that in the in the
bin even otterby says look don't look at
it as material or immaterial look at it
this way let's look at what we really
know what do we know via experience
because don't forget me
in materialism and dualism is all
inferred it's all known by the mind
logic logic and I'm a lover of logic but
I also have a strong criticism of logic
that I'll get to later go ahead I wanted
to because I want you to share this
story this this situation between you
and your father that had a tremendous
impact on you it gave you the edge when
he asked you who do you love more your
mother or God alright talk about that
this is very important I think the
nucleus of every human mind has to be
unbreakable
so for instance if you base your life on
your career well you'll always be
secretly you'll always be insecure no
matter how much confidence you project
why because your career could always
vanish could always break down and
eventually you're gonna die soon and
you'll be separated from your career and
as you get older the years go faster and
faster so a child who goes from the age
of one years old to two years old that
one year was 50% of his life that was a
tremendous amount of time however once
you hit 13 14 15 every year now is a
fraction of your life and the older you
get the faster the year comes around why
because it's actually a smaller
percentage of your life so when you're
99 years old and you go to a hundred
years old that was 1% of your life
whereas that same year when you were 1
years old that's 50% of your life it
seemed so much longer an expiration date
is coming here not only is it coming
it's coming at you at speed your health
it's coming at you exquisitely faster
death is coming to you faster and faster
and faster yeah so if you for instance
marry somebody you're in love with and
you base your life around them secretly
secretly you'll always be insecure why
because that person gets sick that
person can leave you et cetera et cetera
you can do it around money money can
leave you you can go broke the IRS can
come and knock on your door tomorrow
they can take your money from you
whether you're right in the right or the
wrong when I was young and the Imam
asked me will you love more God or your
mother and I said my mother because I
was a child and that's what I understood
he told me what if you
one day she gets ill or whatnot he
wanted me to let go of the world the
dunya don't chase the dunya so to speak
make always a law number one and I
understood that from a young age so
whenever I was growing up and I was I
lost something I loved I would say God
if you're patient he'll replace it with
something better I had a strong
resilience to negative experiences if I
was scared or worried I would just say
inshallah I'll put my trust in God and
this gave me a very strong level of
confidence because who could take god
from you who can be more powerful than
God and I didn't have the level of
insecurities that I think a lot of my
childhood friends growing up did the
fear of dying of being sick of being
separated from something you enjoy and
love and I think this is an experience
that no human being should be without
mm-hmm I don't think you can be truly
happy because even when you find
happiness you it always comes with a
level of insecurity a sadness that
you're gonna be parted with it sooner or
later so friends if you're an atheist
and I give you a beautiful wife woman
child career hobby it's gonna be harder
to let go at that moment of death mhm if
I gave you a horrible life you but like
look death is around the corner I see
you see death is a good thing now maybe
having a horrible life made that easier
for you there's always hope there's
always hope but somebody who is hasn't
as a mentality that he's atheist mmm-hmm
in my opinion can never leat rule
e-enjoy he the human experience
why because death was sour at all so to
speak mmm-hmm because so what's your
this is what inevitably leads you to
nihilism if you're very intelligent and
you're atheistic you're headed down a
path we call nihilism and to this date I
know a lot of you can be like no not me
no no to this day nobody has ever given
as a solution to nihilism to this day
you know Nietzsche tried with the over
man there's many philosophies out there
that I've tried people still suffer from
nihilism find not nihilism nihilism is
that there's no
more nihilism is there's no meaning
purpose to life you're an accident
you're an accident so what if your
children survive and procreate so what
if you survive and reproduce so what
it's all for nothing your life is a
blink of an eye
you're just as insignificant as the ant
you stepped on you didn't stop and bury
him and have a ceremony so what if you
live or die so what if you get cancer or
not we don't care there's no point in
carrying it's all just so temporary
however this is this is the burden of a
very intellectual human being they'll
understand they can look back at the
world and say so what however this is
the fate of somebody who believes this
life is all there is
which is also illogical and unscientific
as well unscientific and I could say
that as confidently as anything else and
if if people are gonna jump out of their
seat down see how could he say that
because you have a weak understanding of
science if you think it's unscientific
it's because you have a weak
understanding of science not a strong
understanding of science if you're a
scientist that doesn't make you a
philosopher of science because be what
people don't understand is philosophy is
based on history philosophy is the
belief that the future will behave like
the past if we're talking about
empiricism empiricism science is the
belief that the future will behave like
the past I know it's a little bit weird
but this is the philosophy of science
now your history of life is that you
came from a non living entity so let me
give you a Socratic example I'll give
you a scrap I'll make it really simple
yeah really simple if I say Eddie you
woke up at seven o'clock if it's a fact
that means that 6:30 you were doing what
or six 6:59 you were doing what you were
sleeping to wake up you had to be
sleeping if I say Eddie you fell asleep
at 9:00 p.m. that means at 8:59 I'm
alleging you were awake to fall asleep
you had to be awake if I say Eddie
you've grown that means before you were
smaller smaller generation comes from
its
so for you to grow bigger you have to
first be smaller for you to go smaller
you first have to be bigger it's
undeniable we cannot deny that the
opposites are generated from one another
mm-hmm you were born on a particular day
yeah yes so before that you were what
some people are hesitate here they want
to say I was nonliving nonliving is just
a semantics for dead you were nonliving
you came to life that's why Allah says
in the Quran when one person asked will
Allah raise us from the dust tell him
like you were created the first time I
was gonna create you again why this is a
message to those who know if you have
scientific understanding if you
understand the philosophy of science
Allah says look at the dunya you're
gonna find my science what do you
refined now we find patterns and
regularities science is the study of
patterns and regularities patterns and
regularities found in nature now I might
be speaking of maybe a is a bit maybe
too deep here okay but Allah is telling
you look at the patterns and
irregularities found in nature Allah
doesn't change his ways meaning you you
came from death Allah Allah brought you
to life from nothing and when you die I
was gonna bring you back it's gonna be
cyclical again just like everything in
nature is cyclical
so the only scientific knowledge you
have about life and death is that you
came from there that's the only
scientific knowledge you have and that
you've observed in nature death come
from life all the time Allah says the
grass dies Allah sends the rain and the
grass grows again all you've seen is
death and life death and life death and
life you've seen the cycle over and over
again
we're like seeds that are gonna be
planted in the ground sha Allah and you
see those fruit seeds vegetable seeds
they come up the human seeds they're
gonna come up tell us since your that
you're an expert in this area of
philosophy weren't Aristotle and Plato
weren't these the co2 fires of the
modern day logic and weren't they the
ones when you look back if you want to
talk about logic they believed in a
higher being they believed them they did
god they did but they had skewed they
had a skewed free about the skewed okay
we know but but this is a very poor dog
let's stay but let's talk about the
school as well let's talk it's very
important okay
it's very believe me now here's the
thing they were theists they were
theists yes they believed the Creator
created and he left it to function on
its own there's there's there's
something called deism the ISM is like
okay there's God God kind of wanted [ __ ]
yeah let it go and this here's what mm
aha Sally well that's just like you now
making your Tristar Academy and then you
just disappeared
alright that doesn't make sense right
yeah I agreed but let's let's talk about
something really important let's talk
about something so important that let's
just say if you if you didn't understand
anything else's conversation if I felt
if I felt like I will if you felt like I
was rambling just listen to this and and
think about this if you're not gonna
think about anything else think about
this the human being has three ways of
knowing something three ways okay let's
call the three primary ways
super simple one you can know something
via experiences your sight senses touch
smell hearing your senses when you were
born you touch something hot your sense
of touch told you it was hot you believe
that mmm
call us that was enough proof for you
it's hot it's done you taste something
sweet you said this things are sweet
you didn't think is this an illusion is
this true or untrue Hollis it was enough
for you to believe it as you were
developing this is what imam hassan ali
says then after certain age you start to
use logic logic is the second way we
know things you start to say hey if I
have an empty basket and I put one Apple
inside and I put a second Apple inside
there's two apples if somebody comes and
takes one apple out I know via logic
there's one left logic now your logic is
gonna correct the first way you know
something your empirical that at your
experience so for instance in Mohali
gives a great example he says look he
says my eyes tell me that shadow is not
moving however if I sit here for six or
seven hours I'm gonna see that shadow
move like a sundial right the Sun moves
therefore the shadow moves
but if you looked at the shadow with
your eyes and you took the information
your eyes gave you the eyes told you
that shadow does not move but your
intellect as you know the shadow moves
your eyes are lying to you
so the intellect supersedes my
experience my empirical knowledge so for
instance Descartes gives a great example
he said look you put a straw in a glass
of water the straw bends yeah he says my
eyes tell me it's bent
I don't believe them I believe my
intellect who tells me no it's the the
rays of light that bent via the water
it's an illusion don't believe your eyes
they intellect is the master of your
eyes Aristotle saw the Sun every day go
around the earth he believed his eyes
and he said look the Sun goes around the
earth Aristotle as logical as he was the
master of logic he believes something
faulty he believed that the earth was
the center of the universe and the Sun
went around the earth North I got a
return didn't of course it was an
optical illusion mm-hmm Vakil they
intellect or patterns the empirical
knowledge so nobody day will say
empirical knowledge is superior to
intellectual knowledge any mama has
daddy says what if a new type of
knowledge comes in usurps
intellect now what and this is where the
beauty of Islamic philosophy is really
because the the Greeks stayed only with
the logic they didn't accept intuition
they don't talk about intuition very
little careful I hear a handful however
it's a central theme in in Muslim
philosophy which I find to be really
incredible mm-hmm
so for instance we know things
intuitively so here's a great example
for those of you who don't know what
intuition is and in science in hard
science for those of you who love hard
science they call it the hard problem of
consciousness okay your consciousness
you don't know it via your conscious
human being yes you're having a
first-person experience do you know this
scientifically so if I were to come with
my team of scientists cut your head off
image I cannot measure it
Leibniz gave a great example like
says imagine I was really really tiny
and I was walking around inside your
mind I would see blood flow I would see
neurons firing but I wouldn't see
anything conscious my empirical data
cannot give me anything conscious I
cannot know who what your experience is
okay so strike empiricism off the table
stipes tripe strike scientific data off
the table science cannot tell us science
is not absolute science has a limit okay
what about your intellect can I
logically deduce that you have
consciousness I cannot logically deduce
you have consciousness no the only
reason I believe you have consciousness
is because I am experiencing
consciousness intuitively intuition is
direct knowledge doubt as the Muslim
philosophers would say doubt by taste
meaning first-person experience your
consciousness is only known via this one
way we call intuition it's not known
scientifically or mathematically so if
you only believe in these two ways of
knowing something you're missing out on
a whole universe of reality actually
we're more sure of our consciousness
than we are of the world around us later
if we ever if we have the time I'll
explain to you the greatest mystic
obsession in human history yeah the
greatest misconception in human history
that throughout my years of talking to
people philosophers not even 1% of
philosophers understand this notion not
even 1% of the philosophers but it is
back to what I was saying how do we know
you're conscious well only intuitively
so people are still when I tell them
this they can't wrap their mind around
it so I give them this thought
experiment let me give you a great
thought experiment that I think of how
people understand at home more easily
what I'm trying to say okay we're gonna
build a robot ok this is a thought
experiment gonna build a robot this
robot is called Eddie 2.0 instead of
eyes we're gonna give them cameras
instead of skin we're gonna have sheet
metal instead of bones we're gonna have
steel aluminum steel instead of blood
we're gonna have oil instead of a brain
we're gonna put a circuit board instead
of
your genetics we're gonna put an
algorithm etc etc he's just like you he
talks like you he acts like you is IQ
was the same as humor is the same his
temperament is the same the only
difference is he still no conscious hold
on
that's hold on let's hold on we're gonna
see what worldview you have yeah he's
exactly like you as a matter of fact
when I pinch him he says ouch he says
ouch
he's programs the program he's program
feel pain he's program he has sensors on
his body that tell him that this sensor
has been triggered at this level of a
force interpreted as ouch because Eddie
would do that
mm-hmm therefore he mimics you
identically one day I come and I destroy
Eddie 2.0 you're going to jail I might
go to jail then I came in vandalism more
than a felony
No then I commit vandalism or murder and
vandalism vandalism yeah what is was he
missing conscious consciousness what is
consciousness what is this thing soul
what is the soul what is it what is it
how do you know it yeah how do you know
it that's my question to you you only
know it via dull taste first-person
experience intuition and in Western
society we would say intuition
now even our abhi
I just started recently reading his text
and then he said something so brilliant
so brilliant that I thought that he said
it best better than anybody I've ever
read
he says look don't think about it as
soul or material don't think about it
like that think about it like this think
about it as seen and unseen have you
seen your soul no have you seen the
dunya the world around you you've seen
it you've seen the material you've seen
your body yeah so this is okay all we
know is seen and unseen
don't say material a material that we
don't know Allah Allah means God knows
best don't say that this is an
interpretation this is not dull this is
not direct experience he says look drop
your intellectual knowledge for a second
and just tell me what you know via
experience doubt first-person experience
nobody can doubt it your first producing
experience so for instance if I pinch
you
and you feel the pain the pain you
cannot doubt it you felt at first person
you can doubt who pinched you you can
doubt even if I pinched you however you
can't doubt the experience of pain
that's that's known directly I can tell
you know you were dreaming I was
pinching you you're actually asleep in
your bed and you're being bit by an end
okay but the pain is real the intuition
is no doubt undoubtable intuition we
cannot doubt even the most critical
philosopher the most the greatest
skeptic cannot doubt the actual
intuition to it of experience mmm take
my word for it for now what do you think
when you see the modern day I would say
profit of atheists is what's his name
doesn't matter uh there are many there
he's the main guy if you say Charl
Dawkins I think Dawkins darkness he's
horrible philosopher all due respect to
Dawkins fans out there but there was
someone he makes so many logical errors
when he speaks it's it's striking but
there was someone who was for 50 years
he was another we would say prophet of
atheists he was a very staunch atheist
50 years propagating it but recently not
too long ago years back he wrote a book
Anthony flew have you heard of him and
speaking about there is a God so when
you see people like this now and people
they put all their trust all their hope
into someone like this and now you're
talking with them and there's they
mentioned what's his name again
the guy we lock in dr. Richard Dawkins
Richard Dawkins said Richard so they're
quoting doc Dawkins and they're going
away from what we're talking about the
natural state the intuition and now many
people following their desires and their
blindly following you know so they're
saying oh you know so they're just happy
they're putting all their faith right
faith with based on no science based on
no evidence they just following him
blindly but then then you have other
individuals like this if you look up
Anthony few he was way bigger than him
fifty years and there's many then you
have also one more and you can take it
from here I don't know if you've heard
of the Oxford study fifty two academics
for us fifty-two this was you know
Oxford University is not a religious
University twenty different countries
and philosophy psychiatry anthropology
they all concluded
Jokke what you're saying that this is
something part of the human we're
programmed to believe no there's no
around it okay first of all you because
your consciousness is staring at you in
the face you cannot deny it but you're
doing what you cannot deny you're
covering it up you're covering it up now
look let's change the topic here let's
talk about Richard Dawkins okay so
listen
I would assume all due respect to
Richard Dawkins and all the fans out
there I say this up most respect I just
don't agree with him and let me give you
a rational explanation why don't and if
you agree with me you agree with me if
you don't agree with me let's just keep
it civil yes you know I'm not have
anything personal against the man I
respect the man he's intellectual when
it comes to biology I'm listening when
it comes to reason and philosophy I all
due respect I just don't feel he's he's
cross examine his his his position well
enough for people who've never heard who
is what's he say he says look there is
no God it's only science science can
prove God okay well let me tell you
something okay if if Dawkins is a seven
on ten in terms of skepticism I'm a nine
point nine compared to him I'm far more
skeptical than a Richard Dawkins he's
not skeptical enough in my opinion
here's why I believe Richard Dawkins
actually believes in many gods I accuse
Richard Dawkins all due respect to
everybody out there I know you're gonna
sound it sounds ridiculous give me a
chance to to rectify to to explain my
position I believe he's a he believes in
many gods
so he's a polytheist pagan he thinks he
believes in things that I find are
nonsensical yes they're fake deities let
me give you a for instance okay let me
give you a fun example let's keep
Richard Dawkins name again this is not a
personal attack okay yeah okay I have a
theory okay you're gonna love this
theory it's called the gremlins theory
okay but before I tell you about my
gremlins theory I'm gonna tell you about
this other guy's theory his name is
Isaac Newton Isaac Newton believes that
hey you don't fall off the face of the
earth because of this force called
gravity he says look the the earth has a
greater mass therefore has a greater
gravity so it attracts you to the earth
you don't fall off the face of the earth
because of gravity well I will tell Sir
Isaac Newton with all due respect I got
a competing theory again don't forget
this is a thought experiment everybody
okay I actually don't believe in this
competing theories
thought experiment I believe that there
are gremlins that hold you down
invisible gremlins they pull you down
they have these incredible [ __ ] that
are infinitely long and they pull you
down to the earth these invisible
gremlins they live on matter and the
reason why I don't fall off the earth is
because they're continuously lassoing
you down to the earth or pull you down
to the earth they're pulling you down to
the earth they're pulling it down to the
earth and you're gonna be like coach
that's ridiculous why is it ridiculous
why is my theory ridiculous and Isaac
Newton's theory is not ridiculous he's
gonna say well because his theory of
gravity correlates with nature so does
my great theory of gremlins I made up
gremlins like he made up this force of
gravity he says gravity I say gremlins
I'm using on purpose and mythological
language I'm using a funny language you
know is not true you know I can't be
serious
but I'm giving you the same logical
equivalence my argument has the same
logical equivalence as Sir Isaac Newton
now don't try don't even bother invoking
Occam's razor because that's a it's not
a logical it's not a it's not a question
of it's not that that's a matter of I'm
sorry I'm doing Ramadan my blood Sugar's
low it's not a criteria for truth okay
all due respect Occam's razor is not a
criteria for truth when we have time
I'll discuss Occam's razor because it's
not a criteria for truth okay Isaac
Newton says look there's this invisible
force that holds you down to the earth
I'm telling you there's an invisible
force as well however minor gremlins and
they have last holes which one of these
is true he's gonna say well look at
nature the moon is smaller than the
earth and it's consistent with my theory
this earth has more gravity therefore it
pulls the moon to the earth I'm gonna
say look my gremlins live on atoms
there's more atoms in the earth
therefore there's more gremlins they're
pulling this the moon to the earth my
gremlin theory will correlate just as
well as the theory of gravity when Isaac
Newton proposed the theory of gravity
his contemporaries said his peers said
that's witchcraft that's magic you're
making
appeal to magic we don't believe in your
theory of gravity however was slowly
adopted because his theory correlated
with what we saw in the world however
today we know he was wrong
today we know Einstein came around and
said look it's impossible there is no
pulling force it's a pushing force and
he he correlated to a whole different
reason one day maybe inshallah we'll
have the time I will talk about how
Einstein debunked the theory of gravity
it was a mythical God that they believed
in now do you think the Arabs they
didn't understand these do you think the
Poli the fake gods of the herbs were any
different when the Arabs saw turban fly
in the fly because of the wind you know
the desert you have strong winds when
the turban was flying in the air and
they said that this is the god of wind
they made up a God they made up a deity
what people don't understand about
science and again this is one percent of
the population science is only patterns
and regularities found in nature the
forces these laws of nature or things we
project from our minds onto nature now
this is very profound and I and I
understand that it's very profound but
gravity electricity magnetism all these
forces or exactly what the Arabs
projected and Islam came to wipe out we
believe and I don't want to tell people
we don't believe in science we believe
in science but these are just bookmarks
these things don't exist out there the
Muslim mind the educated Muslim mind
sees these as bookmarks how I'll prove
to you that this is the Islamic point of
view when Allah describes the bird that
flies in the air mm-hmm by what power is
this bird Flying Nun holds the bird up
in here but Allah but the Creator yeah
didn't the Arabs know about wind and
lift of course they did what the Muslim
mind understands is that what you're
seeing are images patterns and
regularities all power goes back to the
one there are nope there is no power
outside of Allah so Allah there is none
every other power you attribute to
something else is a type of [ __ ] that's
some type of minor [ __ ]
do you actually believe there's a force
out there other than God this is not the
Islamic position if you read a lot
Sheree or Imam Ghazali this is known as
occasional ISM the Muslim believes that
all power comes from allah subhanaw
taala
nature is nothing but patterns and
regularities patterns and regularities
found in nature we attribute forces to
them so for instance one common false
god is randomness they say Oh what
brought you to this world randomness
where is this daily amount as Ali would
tell you demonstrate randomness - for us
can anybody demonstrate randomness I've
been asking this question for many years
I haven't seen a single case of
randomness in my in my history of
philosophy now let me explain to you a
little bit about randomness for instance
ok let's take for instance that the
Laplace theory the Laplace example ok
let's look at a billiard balls on the
table if I hit the billiard balls you
know a pool right here's the pools are
racked if I tell the physicists hey I'm
gonna hit this ball at this angle at
this at this force he's gonna go and
he's gonna measure the weight of every
ball the friction of the table the
density of the band's the angle he's
gonna take all those numbers and I put
them on a blackboard he's gonna turn
that table into mathematics and then
he's gonna tell me where every ball is
gonna land so I hit the I hit the break
I hit it that the force and angle I told
him I would he's gonna calculate it he
knows where every ball is gonna land yes
yeah it looked random to the layman the
layman would like oh they're gonna
scatter randomly no no no it's not
random Laplace tells you there's no
randomness in this universe there is no
randomness this universe if we were to
reset it the way it was before the Big
Bang or whatever you want to call it and
every everything was the same as it was
we're gonna have the exact same universe
we have today there is no force of
randomness let me make it let me make it
even more clear let me make it even more
clear for you picture a catapult
I like this catapult example picture I
can hold and I fire a catapult and the
rock lands on point a it bounces on the
ground that ends on point a and now I'm
gonna reset the universe back to where
before
catapulted it yes I'm gonna get every
hair every strand of fiber on the Rope
is reput every molecule of errors reset
every blade of glass is reset every dust
on the rock was we put the universes
back to where it was and I fire the
catapult again is it gonna land on Point
a exactly again or is it gonna land
somewhere around that area or is it
gonna be specifically pointy what do you
think it would land if I reset this
circumstance exactly back to the
originals original you should repeat
this it should repeat identical yeah
so I can reset the the environment
identically to the first time I kind of
bolted it it will land identically to
the first part now where if if
randomness is a force out there in the
universe and not a force inside your
head if it's not just imaginary how come
it didn't play in our experiment you
know there are machines they build
machines that flip coins mm-hmm they
flip coins in the air and they could
tell you it's gonna land on heads and
their rate of success is 100% they could
flip it 100 times and get a correct 100
times they're telling you the machine
was built to explain to you that
randomness doesn't exist randomness is a
figment of our imagination yeah
randomness is the human being saying I
cannot compute all the data therefore
I'm gonna invoke a God called randomness
you know a lot of times atheists will
say oh it's the God of the gaps every
time you don't understand something you
say God did it
well the atheists also have their God of
the gaps they call it randomness
whenever they cannot compute all the
information out there they invoke a
deity a false god and they call them
randomness and they say this is our God
well I say me this is a reflection of
our ignorance when we see something as
random we say this is a reflection of
our ignorant so we cannot compute all
this mathematical data therefore we have
the illusion of randomness if somebody
this is a this is an Islam would be seen
as lacking taqwa because if you think of
Allah you would say oh no this is all
computer by Allah to me its randomness
so a lot it's not random that's what we
call a lot of luck yeah the truth yes so
for instance
imagine a man would come to you and say
the tallest mountain I've ever seen is
the tallest mountain there is would you
think this is a wise man or an ignorant
man he's straighten it if he's saying
that the white the tallest mountain I've
ever seen is the tallest mountain there
ever must be there must be no other
Mountain mm-hmm you must not travel much
he must not travel much he must not be
the wisest man why because he doesn't
know the extent of his own ignorance
that mountain could be relatively very
small I was actually at the highest
mountain in Bosnia no really yeah
interesting I think it was house that
was up in the clouds go ahead I'm sorry
but I'm amazing see when you take
yourself as the center of the world it's
a type of idolatry you say I'm the
measure of truth mm-hmm it's a type of
idolatry you see a theism is really a
type of idolatry all due respect I
believe there's atheism polytheism and
agnosticism yeah but I don't believe
there's a theism I don't believe in that
see the term kafar people think it's a
derogatory term it's not at all who far
means literally comes from the root word
of covering what are you covering you're
covering your belief in God a cool
father is not an insult it's somebody
you know in Islam we believe in
pre-existence a lot of Muslims might not
know this we believe before we came into
this world you gave you a Shahada yes in
the Quran it says Allah he offered the
test of this dunya to the dunya and they
didn't want it but dunya didn't want it
he gave it to us yes we declare Allah or
one Lord you gave your Shahada before
coming in this world so when you're born
a natural state of a human being is to
be believing in God so what that's one
thing I always like to ask people can
you find one society that didn't have a
religion find one it's not there doesn't
exist anthropologists they can't they
can't find one no find one that's the
socks for a study that's what they
concluded the right yeah now why because
you're born with something called the
fitrah now Islam is the first religion
yeah I call it the God's plan
yes now the fitrah let me ask you
something the fitrah the fitna is the
primordial belief okay you're born with
this belief for those who don't know the
word fitrah is Islam the first religion
or a new religion is Islam or a new
religion or the first religion
is Islam known as the first religion in
Islam do we hold did the prophet sallahu
salaam teach us that the religion of
islam is new it started in the 600 or is
it the first religion of Adam we say
it's the first religion of Adam a nice
that's right why because you're born
Muslim even if you've never heard of the
Quran or the Prophet Muhammad - profound
you're born Aslam you're born Muslim
because Adam was told to submit that's
what Islam you submit to God it would be
very true but he was also born with the
Deen born with this Deen yes he was born
with the Dean the Dean is born with it
now let me tell you one of my favorite
books and I've read countless books my
favorite book one of my favorite books
is haben yuxun hae-bin the exam is very
interesting book one it's very touching
because it's the first philosophical
novel written in history second it's
written by a Muslim scholar a mentor
file and thirdly it's all about Islam
finding the fitrah mm-hmm haben EXN is a
young man is also by the way at the
story of Tarzan was taken by a from
Haven EXN he's a young man who finds
himself on an island without a mother
and he's raised by a doe a female deer
now one day this doe she dies now all he
know he doesn't know language he doesn't
know any anything a human he has no
doctrine except the natural doctrine he
was born in now she dies one day the
Fond the mother his mother the the the
deer she dies now this is his first
encounter with death and he'd noticed
that when he blocked his ears his ears
won't work
and when he cover his eyes his eyes
don't work if you blocked his nose his
nose doesn't work so he said look her
life must be blocked somehow this isn't
me remember this is a very primitive
thought these are early human thoughts
hypothesized mmm-hmm so he says there
must be something that's blocking her
whole body her whole system well it must
be in the center of her body why because
that would be the place for the thing
that blocks the entire system so he
invent
does an autopsy and finds the heart now
he goes on to a
journey to find what is that thing what
we found earlier about the robot yeah he
was missing that we said is not known
logically or scientifically it's only
known via this one very particular way
called intuition and then he goes from
there he has a very religious experience
and finds himself he's a Muslim he
understands his relationship with the
Creator now there's a lot to Islam
outside of just the rules and
regulations of Islam yes this is a very
important part of Islam but there is the
the realm of tasawwuf the spiritual
realm and if you read them early Muslim
philosophers the central theme was
finding this getting to this level worst
Muslims today it's more about the
benefits of following Jewish prudence
the the traditions or the rituals the
rituals are extremely important no doubt
about it
however equally important even more
important is tasawwuf or the
purification of the heart
now purification havahart has many
levels but this is known intuitively and
these these these these incredible body
of literature I think has to be revived
in OMA the Muslims so they have to go
back and reread that because not only
were they great logical thinkers in my
opinion there's surpassed logic mm-hmm
and I think that's an important segment
we should talk about because a lot of
people jump out of their seat almost all
the time I have I want to I want to I
want to get in a few more questions sure
that I been wanting to ask you I want to
just make a comment on I like what you
said and this is what we believe that
there is no one that's truly an atheist
and even an atheist if you follow his
life you'll see him going through her
going through a set of rituals and
certain things will happen in her life
and it becomes good luck bad luck and
this can be traced back to the god of
fortune Fortuna I don't know that I've
seen a lot of people they might be
atheist but they're knocking on wood you
follow me this is actually if you if you
study this this is an ancient
Scandinavian tree God to stay away they
has to hit that to knock to wake up oh
yeah so it's amazing but when you see
now I'm very happy I'm elated to see
someone like you someone who
has become well-known in the martial
arts community because a lot of times
the crater loss Montella gives someone a
spotlight and now there's a lot of
pressure on Muslims nowadays a lot of
Islamic phobia is a huge industry and
they're scaring the Islam out of people
so Mo's Muhammad's becoming moe right or
he's become a ostrich with his head in
the ground but you're proud to be a
Muslim but how do you feel when you see
a religion that you love that you
practice being maligned out there what
do you have you had these interactions
with some of your students or have you
have some bullies some cyber bullying
people call of course Orestes you deal
with it the second I say anything
remotely is slightly look at the West
this is divided into camps it's people
who are tolerant people who are
intolerant the West is predicated on
everybody can can be part of the West
everybody doesn't matter your color your
create etc your class so they're just
being under being untrue to the
Constitution mm-hmm I don't when
somebody says something ignorant I feel
sorry for them that they're ignorant I
don't hold his criteria of ignorance to
be a measure of truth or that it's gonna
it's gonna harm me in any way I don't
have any how should I say I don't waste
my time with them or I feel honestly I
just feel sorry for them mm-hmm for
instance today I was online I posted
something and somebody said something
really really violent towards me yeah
because he knows I'm Muslim
so you ever experienced an office all
the time listen did you know what my
channels are very clean hamdullah
and I try to reciprocate this respect
but of course but I feel sorry for him
because he has to live ignorant what's
worse being an ignorant person walking
around the earth or being somebody who's
hoping not to be ignorant to try to shed
himself from ignorance which one of the
two has a better experience a human
experience many success stories of
removing some ignorant scores probably
having to connect and we always usually
encourage people to make the human
connection has anyone
who've had that that thought of mine
connected with you and actually a
success story so you were able to remove
many of those layers of ignorance well
listen
yes the countless countless times I've
had profound conversations their private
with countless people I mean I traveled
the globe what are some of the top two
three misconceptions that you were here
you know what a lot of conceptions come
from Mumbai itself Muslims themselves
they have to understand what the Deen is
who are the greatest minds of Islam what
this what did they understand about
Islam and Islam is a direction in my
opinion it's a direction the Prophet
Salla assalam and Islam and Islam was so
progressive in their time they were the
most merciful the most just they were it
was absurd that the camel has rights
these are things that were absurd that a
woman has rights is Lomb was
progressively going in a direction step
by step for instance islam abolished
slavery but one step at a time
in the West we abolish slavery with a
violent war now we both did something
great the west and the east now I'm I'm
a Muslim I'm from the East my roots are
from the east but I'm more in the West
I'm in the middle ok take me as
impartial here for a second I love Islam
and I love the West but the West had a
bloody battle to free the slaves it's
not we didn't have Aslam taught us this
master and the slave they're equal only
there add up only their good manners one
is better than the other yeah you have
it beautifully written in your dojo by
the way every sin part you want to be
pardoned you want to make it right with
Allah free a slave free a slave every
verse in the Quran there's so many verse
in the Quran free a slave what's Islam
the freeing of a slave free a slave
we're so encouraged to free a slave that
you're going to be embarrassed to have a
slave but yet we didn't take the slave
out of your hand because there would be
it may be a economical destabilization a
civil war why did the whites not want to
free the slaves well it was the whites
that wanted to free the slaves the
poorer White's the poor whites said look
the black slaves are taking our jobs
they lower our wages because they're
free labor
it was the whites they wanted to free
the slaves in the boîte and another
group of whites that they don't want to
free the slaves now in Islam
the mop men the righteous he's happy to
free the slave it's a righteous thing to
do we resolved slavery in a different
way but today has in the east and the
West we don't have slavery okay as long
as by increments increments what is the
direction Islam was going now some
Muslims today they want to say no
whatever was done in that time that's it
hit the brakes don't progress I believe
that the principles have to remain true
however the exact manners per se again
it is not my opinion a Muslim scholar
asked the Muslim scholars the majority
of them will tell you that it's a
direction we have to be a little bit
more modernized in our thinking is LOM
was a direction because Islam in it in
its 23 years of Revelation also moved
forward and changed why that's the
example that's the very principle that
we are progressive we are progressive
yes a quick change might have been too
much for the Arabs and change in Islam
is done the correct way to change in
Islam is incrementally yeah that's why
if you're a new Muslim start slow don't
pray 50 times a day start with the
fighted start with the five yeah start
with the minimum make it easy once
that's easy add extra hmm
don't make it all about ritual not a
maximum amount of ritual Islam supposed
to be easy right transition is made easy
so I think a lot of Muslims today they
have lack for lack of a better term dumb
down the religion and David Dunn we've
done the most harm to ourselves why
because when you tell the Muslims today
who is aiming to fail they don't know
who's Imam Ghazali they don't know you
know there's a hadith that says every
hundred years there's gonna be someone
who's gonna come and bring back the
religious reform it like somebody we're
gonna be like we're gonna follow
somebody would have great admiration for
every hundred years now every hundred
years we debate who is that man except
one one century we didn't debate that
was the year of imam hassan ii
in the year of him every member has
sadly everybody agreed he's the one
nobody's greater than him What did he
say most Muslims didn't read him Hasani
he mama has daddy says when you hold
something to be true bring me a
demonstration or else strike it from the
record he was the most skeptical so if
you brought him gravity
he would say demonstrate me gravity
that's your uncle that's your intellect
you could not demonstrate me gravity so
therefore you put it in the maybe pile
plausible
and then Einstein comes along and
disproves gravity as Einstein and as
Isaac Newton understood it a pulling
force but this wouldn't have happened to
him a Mahadi because the emember has
already said I must know things via
intuition though yeah which brings me
back maybe man oh we're running out of
time to my one point I would like to
bring up even our abhi he says look
don't cut things don't divide things as
material or immaterial your body's
material your consciousness is
immaterial use the link language of the
Quran the Crown's gonna point us to
something very wondrous he says look
look at as seen and unseen you seen your
body yeah but you haven't seen your soul
you've experienced your soul directly
intuition but you haven't seen it so we
have the scene and we have the unseen
now when Allah spawn with Allah when God
makes Adam Ali Salaam he takes him from
the soil the soil is seen the soil you
can see it
then he breathes into him his rule the
rooh the spirit of God the rule has
Arabic word I hate to use translation
because there's so many problems with
translation but God breathes into him
something unseen and even Rav says when
this seen and unseen came together now
we have man Adam alayhi Salam the Adam
the ego the self what you associate to
Eddie is not this unseen thing which you
would call the soul per se or now we
will fall into semantics
there's the unseen there's the scene and
then there's this thing sandwiched in
the middle
Adam or man so the story of Adam is a
story as well of direct experience
that you've had yours this fear or this
scene object and you're also part of you
unseen and the one who's witnessing this
interaction because even our abhi takes
a lot of dualities hot/cold
plus - the Shahada la ilaha il-allah
there is no except one the the many the
the one the opposites when we bring them
together
pure monotheism pure monotheism of
course no doubt about it but do you
understand that when you we bring in hot
and cold when we bring in the opposites
we come to something very unique when we
brought the seen and unseen opposites
and we we we experienced them together
we have something very unique that's
born the ego the self your what you hold
as Eddy this one thing the the thing you
call Eddy is sandwiched between the seen
and the unseen and this is the very
story of Adam and of course he has a
very you know even Atta be has a
incredible amount of writing on the
tafseer of the Quran and he's his
nickname was the shekel Akbar shake a
lot about meaning the greatest teacher
now I again he was a prodigy he didn't
have any real teachers growing up and he
was a very enlightened human being again
but this is for the the Muslims today to
be familiar with to know and the fact
the reason why we don't know is in my
opinion why we have so much trouble
mmm-hmm we have such a hard time being
understanding our Deen because our Deen
is very simple and easy to understand
yes we often say that if people can dig
this worship the Creator not the
creation that's where it starts with oh
because you've given in great brilliant
examples of people claiming to be
atheist but there really is no true
atheist they're just covering up that
intuition there and they end up
worshiping themselves believes in
something metaphysical yes
what's metaphysical means literally
beyond physics yeah
so we non-physical he believes in
something about physical when I asked
him to demonstrate it for me he cannot
so we covered that so I strike it I
think if someone has the qualities of
being genuine sincere you explain that
very eloquently we're almost out of time
a couple more things I want to throw at
you is what about
Jesus now many people are Christian
brothers and sisters in humanity
now they say like well you don't
understand God because you don't
understand what about Jesus what do you
guys believe this is this is this is
some excuse me I'm slashing hi in short
so we're almost okay yeah let's make
this really simple I have utmost respect
for my Christian brothers and sisters my
Jewish brothers and sisters they come
from the same Dean as us the same
religion however we do have a critic
criticism of them in the Koran that
their books have been changed now if I
have the idea of God the man who has the
idea of read he couldn't have gotten
this idea without a direct experience I
could not have this experience of God my
soul my rooh my spirit the invisible
world without direct experience I know
about we're talking about it I'm
experiencing it directly I know God via
direct experience I'm having a
transcendent experience right now
meaning it's beyond this world there's
something about me right now
let's beyond this world comes from allah
subhanaw taala if i take this thing and
i look in the mirror and i say i mix the
two together remember we did earlier
when we compounded ideas now I've
committed the most arrogant act a human
being can do I'm saying I am God what's
beautiful in this world well this
transcendent incredible experience I'm
having this consciousness well couple it
with something else you love what do I
love more than me you see Jesus in
Europe
he's blond-haired blue-eyed in Africa
he's black in America he's white
American it's the self love what does it
say in the Quran they take what they
lusts and make them gods hmm so some
people lost their narcissistic per se
now I'm not saying my brothers and
sisters in Christianity or narcissistic
not at all a lot of them are very very
humble human beings I'm saying the
people who started this trend because
when you are born like a member cazali
says when you were born you're the
Muslim say Muslim the Christians become
Christian the Jews become Jews the
atheist become atheist whatever
your parents were that's what you're
likely gonna be so I have I've seen them
to the utmost respect to my brothers and
sisters in the Christianity you're our
forefathers not you per se you were born
in this you were indoctrinated in this
but your forefathers maybe is somewhere
sometime someplace some of them were
narcissistic they said where they were
this type of people we are a particular
culture we are God we are Allah and who
when they're born is not gonna be happy
to hear the hey our race is from Allah
our races God but this is a classic
example of mixture this now is doubt
about let me explain to you why let me
explain to you why okay there's
something very special in the Quran and
Islam that many Muslims don't know can
you differentiate between a belief and
knowledge a belief has a letter meant of
your possibly wrong knowledge knowledge
you cannot be wrong you cannot know
something that's false
you can believe something that's false
but you cannot know it now I'm going to
tell you something that's gonna sound
very strange and this is maybe gonna
sound very cool and if you read the
Muslim scholars the original they'll
tell you the same thing we know Allah
exists we believe in the dunya the dunya
is an illusion the cross is the opposite
see in the Muslim mine Allah 100% true
the dunya is a delusion
like it says in the Quran dunya is an
illusion now if you look at Descartes
now if we're running out of time let's
make more time because this is important
anybody can run a decal uh-huh one of my
favorite philosophers he says look
everything can be doubted it seems so
for instance he says look okay class
example you see the Sun go around the
earth you see it scientifically observe
it every day your forefathers told you
the Sun goes around the earth then one
day you realize an optical illusion
throw that scientific fact out the
window okay all flamingos are pink then
we go to Australia they're black there
what happened oh it turns out it's the
food that they eat that makes them pink
they're originally black or it's the
Swan that's white and then you can have
them black
cetera change the vironment change the
fact a scientific fact water boils at
100 degrees no not true either
we can put water in a certain type of
atmosphere in the liquid that burns at
200 it sorry it boils at 200 degrees
boils water we believed for so long
boils at 100 degrees not a fact it's
actually this water in a particular
circumstance that makes it boil at 100
degrees facts keep getting overturned a
scientific fact if somebody truly
understands science he knows that a
scientific fact can never reach a higher
level than hypothesis Descartes
understood this can't understood this
Plato understood this Kuhn understood
this Imam Ghazali understood this the
greatest minds in the world understood
this now every scientific fact can be
overturned like they've been overturned
in the past they'll be overturned in the
future what about your uncle you're not
you're your logic well there's so many
criticisms to logic but let me give you
an easy one
Aristotle didn't agree with Plato
Voltaire didn't agree with Leibniz Mme
Roselli didn't agree with avicennia Sam
Harris doesn't agree with Peter what's
his name Jordan Peterson the intellect
of our age they don't agree but yet
they're all using the same perfect
knowledge how come they don't agree well
maybe a long maybe logic is maybe the
knowledge logic is perfect but you're
not you make mistakes I make mistakes so
whose logic is so perfect we trusted
nobodies now science is doubt about
logic is terrible there's one thing we
can adopt even the most strict atheist
the most radical skeptic he not cannot
doubt this Descartes called it the
cogito I think therefore I am I have
thoughts I'm having this internal
experiences consciousness I cannot doubt
that I exist because I'm I'm having it
directly I don't need logic and I don't
need
science I learned this intuitively now
he said something I think therefore I am
and and and later
Nietzsche famously critique them you
can't even say I think just I am meaning
existence is true now this is something
very interesting why because the Arabs
understood the Muslim philosophers
understood that there's consciousness
and then there's the content of your
consciousness the content the content of
your consciousness and your mind you
might be dreaming over you might be
thinking of a red apple
I can doubt that red apple maybe it
doesn't exist in the world maybe you
dreamt it up maybe you're thinking of
the marshmallow man however
consciousness cannot be doubted
consciousness is known directly if you
try to doubt it you'd be proving it if
you try to use your logic against it
you'd be proving it if you try to use
doubt against it you'd be proving it
your doubt is the proof your argument is
the proof you cannot doubt it that's why
I lost planet Allah says look inside
yourself for my science now the content
is the created consciousness your whole
world around you is made of
consciousness now I'm in your
consciousness presently right now you're
experiencing me in a dark place inside
your mind your vaio 'pn your mind right
now there wouldn't be this studio it'll
be a dark place yeah if for instance
you're playing a song inside your mind
you're singing a song there's no sound
for saying there's no actual sound but
you hear it somewhere someplace now this
might sound very voodoo okay but this is
this is this is uh this is known
intuitively consciousness and the
contents is not the same we have to make
a difference between the two now
consciousness we know for sure this is a
gift known by Allah this is why i'm emma
has daddy says knowledge comes knowledge
not belief knowledge comes from a lot
it's a gift why because allah didn't
have to give us his consciousness allah
gave us something no physicist can make
you doubt no scientist can make you
doubt no mathematician no atheist no
amount of propaganda can make me doubt
my direct experience of this thing that
not even logic nor science
can encapsulate what did a lot due to
Adam when he formed him from soil he
breathed is in the Quran it's in the
Quran Allah breathed into him something
from somewhere else let's call it now
what does he mama has daddy say about he
says don't talk too much about it
don't try to philosophize they don't try
to bring it back into a logical realm
Allah made logic for you to find his
door not to encapsulate logic does not
encapsulate on las planet allah some
people tell me could God make a rock so
heavy even he can lift it you don't
understand logic my friend all due
respect you've reached only a certain
level of understanding of logic because
logic inherently when you push it to its
limits
it breaks down so for instance we have
something called the liars paradox the
liars paradox is a living contradiction
so for instance if I say this statement
is a lie it's a lie I'm admitting it's a
lie but by saying a lie it's also true
so in one sense it's true in one sense
it's a lie it's referring to itself in
two different ways and at both time at
the bed at once it's both P and not
because in philosophy we tell you there
can never be P and not P P cannot equal
not P yeah but here we have an instance
of P not be together in the same place
logic can only take us so far Allah is
beyond logic Allah is known via doubt
taste experience that's why I'm M&Z he
says you know Allah because Allah
granted you this mercy that's why I'm
anata B he says everything is mercy why
because of this one gift nothing in this
dunya can happen that that takes away
the weight of this gift far outweighs
anything that can happen to in this
dunya for anything that's why Allah is
merciful X cetera now these writings are
beautiful they're profound when I read
these writings okay I don't want to I'm
I'm formally trained in logic their
understanding of logic is so incredible
the arabs when i read them their
understanding of logic is striking
it's profound even some of them were
referred to as the corrector of
Aristotle rightly so I would say rightly
so this reminds me of one of my first
teachers dr. Emil Lee he would tell me
about him on ghazali may Allah have
mercy on him and towards the end of his
life you know how he died he died with
the books of Bihari and Muslim and I
remember was that yes okay not that I
didn't know yeah this was my teacher was
telling me so yeah he studied all of the
philosophies but towards the end he came
he was studying even more the the Hadees
of Bukhari and Muslim he died with that
on his chest was amazing yeah this is
amazing yep have you ever read the
mammoth is that his poem but he left
under his pillow when he died when he
died sure you know it's it's it's a very
beautiful poem that I don't know by
heart unfortunately but fearfully is
what it is it's our I'll butcher it all
right I can't do it justice yeah maybe
you find that I might put anything I'll
share beautiful it's a beautiful poem
I'll share a story when when he died on
his deathbed in the room of this body
they found that unders pillow yeah
beautiful poetry beautiful well tell the
people out there we're out of time for
the person who's tuning in a lot of the
not yet Muslims because I usually say
that because everyone has the potential
and usually people and when they ask are
you Muslim I say define what is your
idea of a Muslim right
if you mean someone who has submitted to
the will of God someone who's trying his
best to be of noble character on is just
and virtuous yes but if you got some
twisted ideas like most people do then
we don't fit that description but now
for that person who does they tune in
they catch us a late night on the TV can
TV and they're tuning in or maybe on the
on the
I'm one of our social media channels
satellite channels whatever and now
they're like what do these Moslems got
to do and they see you they recognize
you
st. George piers training coach and what
are some of the other top fighters
you've tried but I've worked with all of
them so they're like what's this guy
he's Muslim also but they've heard of
lot of different you know Isis and
al-qaeda and all this other crazy mad
stuff but they like a lot of the things
we're talking about worshiped create
another Croatia's our deep love for
jesus is a mighty messenger you broke
down a lot of the logic you know that
we're really critical analytical people
we don't know and it's not blind faith
you know we really thought about doctors
through Islam provides the evidence that
one needs to know confirm that the Quran
is not a book written by a man or a
group of men it is indeed from the
Creator the heavens and earth but now
all these misconception what advice and
short what would you tell them well I
would have two messages one for the
non-muslims every group has a fire right
group fire right problem whether every
single group the Christians have
far-right the atheists have far-right
the Jews have far-right far-right
meaning the people who take things to an
extreme Islam we have a far-right group
they're just very popular in the media
and as Muslims we have to speak out
against the far-right because it's Haram
any way you look at it it's Haram being
an extremist is Haram so for one don't
forget all groups we have far-right
feminism as far-right a theism as
far-right Republicans are far-right
Democrat have far-right everybody's got
a right-wing problem it's not just Islam
Muslims we got to be more verbal and we
got to take more responsibility for a
right-wing problem and we all have to
have a tolerance for one another
if somebody's Christian or atheists are
Jewish or feminists or whatever it
should not bother you it shouldn't
bother you that I'm Muslim and that
you're atheist and they're the earth
Christian and I'm that Muslim or I'm
Muslim and you're Joey
it doesn't it shouldn't bother us why
because you're atheist because you think
it benefits you I'm Muslim because I
think it benefits me
judges why do we have to hate each other
or why the prejudice prejudice comes
from fear so when you have a prejudice
you're telling the world you're scared
and insecure so me I feel I would like
to think that I'm a secure person and
I'm a just person so if Islam is gonna
come to you and Charlotte comes to you
if somebody asks me about Islam I'm
happy to tell them about it if they ask
me not to talk about Islam I'm happy not
to talk to the model either because if
they don't want to hear it that's their
problem between it's between them and
their God it's between them in their
religion so I think what you need first
to understand that extreme extremism
exists in every group and secondly very
importantly half tolerance for one
another because when you don't have
tolerance you're showing your true
insecurities that's the bottom line
thank you brother I pleasure Lee I
appreciate spending some time with you
talking here and Charlotte we can hook
up again sometime Jala just talked about
hi thank you brother
Salaam I can't even Salaam
you